welcome to this video this is a new part
of opening disasters yeah let's have a
look at this game but before we should
look at a very well-known classic
opening trapper opening sequence that is
commonly known as the gods made them
hope i'm hoping to pronounce that about
right yeah it is something that's well
known since the the 19th century or
maybe even earlier i'm not quite sure
i'm going to show this this basic
opening trap to you first so that you
can appreciate why this video is titled
as it is yeah very normal opening moves
and the phila doors defense and now
let's aim right place Bashar see form
like place something like age 6 not
great Knight c3 and now black plays
Bishop g4 yeah Black is pinning the
white knight however in this position
here why it has an excellent move and
this is the essence of them this this
opening trap this opening idea if you
want white now can take on e5 which is
very strong and sacrifices the Queen if
black is not taking the Queen and let's
say you just take the night we just take
on g4 and enjoy an extra porn and the
much better position because we have
lots of pieces developed already and
blankets yeah also just a pawn down okay
so after the Queen capture white has
Bishop f7 check after that there's only
King to e7 and now 95 mate this is
legault made probably pronounced wrong
and but this this is the the motif that
you should keep in mind when we look at
the actual game um yeah
you see the names of the players this
was played in the Belgium leak leak that
I also compete in between to mp2 masters
that are rated around two thousand three
hundred give or take a couple of points
I i only found this game in HS magazine
a couple of years ago and that sort of
yes stuck in my mind because it's really
nice ok we have 96 and now the white
player Martin on goes for the Scotch
opening yeah Black has number of
Defense's one of them is Bishop c5 very
good reply and now he went night b3 the
white player this move on is getting
more popular in recent years also due to
the efforts of Magnus cards and he has
played a number of interesting games
with it connected card with cart with
the idea Queenie to Bishop e3 but the
Aeon plays differently he plays for the
pin Bishop g5 black plays age 6 should
h4 and d6 yeah all very simple and
innocent I think looking moves it's
really looking like okay there's nothing
nothing spectacular happening in this
game however you could not be more wrong
as now why place the move a4a form the
idea is to play a 5 this is not an
uncommon idea in in this opening in fact
this a 4 push sometimes happens a couple
of moves earlier however in this
specific position a for threatening a 5
it's really a big mistake but to
actually exploit this mistake it term is
very helpful to know this idea of the
mate that we have seen before if you
think about this there are some
similarities behind this position and
the classic made seen before there is
the bishop pointing towards f2
win this case it was f7 the other way
around and there is there is this pin
but this is only imperfect pin yeah its
opinion on the Queen so the night can
actually move and it is really the case
if you look at this a little bit more
closely you might spot that Knight takes
e4 is possible and was played in the
game so black actually took the pond and
ignore to the pin really a fantastic
move so what happens now in the game
white took the Queen there is really
yeah this is really the only practical
chance because there is a big attack
also by the Queen yeah other way around
on the bishop so why does not really
having time to do anything else if you
take here like we'll just take on h4 and
he has an extra porn he has two bishops
he's got pressure so this is just just
totally totally meek he took the Queen
this is the best practical decision
everything else is just a pawn down with
a bad position so he took on d 8 yeah
what happens now is this a direct
checkmate it's not but we see that black
gets an enormous attack so black took on
f2 yeah this is the consequence of the
bishop leaving age form we can now take
on f2 which also makes the whole
combination bit more difficult to spot
that f2 is really that week despite the
bishop being on h4 at the beginning of
it okay takes king e to the only move
and now we see what happens black has a
hailstorm of checks Bishop g4 check King
bee three yeah but what now is black
just taking the Queen this is really not
enough you have a much stronger move a
much much stronger move and this is and
now it it gets really great like place
95 check he's giving up yet another
piece and we see that it's somewhat
mind-boggling this position but white
only has kidney for it's the only move
so wyd also took the knight on e4 the
King really taking a big big walk and
now again Black has a check f5 check
forcing the White King even further up
the board there's only King d5 if white
goes to f4 there is a little checkmate
coming yeah so you need to advance even
further up to d5 yeah and this is now
really really looking funny you will see
that whites king is in grave danger but
how is black actually now finishing this
off he found the best way in the game or
maybe he had even looked at this at some
point before hand you never know if they
just thought about it in the game or
maybe they spotted the idea earlier
black now just took the bishop off the
main point of the movies that it's not
really the bishop being taken but the d6
pawn being protected what black wants to
do if he wants to play c6 and get the
King even to e6 Yeah right in the middle
of blacks camp note that blacks black is
really taking away vital squares the
White King cannot go here due to the
great night only five it cannot go to d4
due to the bishop here and if or is also
covered so there our flight squares are
covered in a way if you get in c6 the
White King really has to step up all the
way to e6 and then it's really really
close to made in the game right now
decided to give back the queen with
Queen takes d4 um note that if you look
at the position White has a has a total
extra Queen that's it so it's a it's a
pure Queen that is up okay I ants two
pawns but in terms of pieces and sits a
complete Queen he took on g4 it looks
that looks very desperate but
it is really a big problem here what is
your move besides screen takes a before
if you play something something slow and
let's say you just want to get the Queen
away from the tech yeah they see six
coming look at this and the king where
do you want to go you only got King e6
and after have four of your checkmated
it's really nice so what really cannot
save the queen what you can try to do as
a min 94 it's maybe a tribe trying to
get to get the night to a defensive
position but then black is again playing
c6 king e6 and now comes another point
of the whole operation if black now
plays F for white can actually counter
sacrifice which is not so clear better
is really amazing castles and that idea
is now to play rook f6 check and
checkmate white if you know save the
queen here there is this additional
checkmate yeah checkmating the white key
on yet it's really funny if you would
give someone this position now if they
somehow can reconstruct the whole game
how did the White King end up on the aid
it's really nice yeah so there are many
many funny checkmates coming yeah why
took on g4s mentioned he wanted to
somehow yup fend off the attack by
getting rid of one of the pieces he is
still appears up yeah if black would
just recapture on g4 which is in fact
not not terribly bad but it's not not
the best move the point is if you take
now white all of a sudden gets a flight
square for the King on e4 therefore it
is better not to take the Queen but
first to play the move c6 check oops I'm
sorry this was wrong I was here and now
it's best to play the move c6 check
first
like this and now the White King has to
go to be 6 there is there are no
alternatives King in six and now at this
point black actually could have taken
the Queen it's not it's not a bad move
but he decided to do something else he
castled fantastic I just I just love
this like it's just ignoring the Queen
hanging and is some setting up mating
threads instead yeah white cannot save
the queen it's really it's really the
case if why this is going back let's say
Here I am then we have this mate coming
up again saw that before so castles is
really setting up a maid threat this is
great yeah Queen txt form is met with
castles so what is the possible defense
if white tries to sacrifice the Queen
that's another checkmate what should why
do there is an interesting move to try
to defend this and this is Queen to see
form at first I thought that this could
be a clever idea yeah I know it looks
like it's blundering the Queen but well
we're happy if black takes and we're
still a piece up then or two pieces even
and the night only five is a super
important attacking piece after Queen c4
we need to be careful really careful
because we can easily stumble as black
if black goes rook f6 check here then
why it has King e7 check check is the
big problem and we oops wrong wrong
arrow we have this rookie checked all of
a sudden so white with the king is
giving a sort of discovered check quite
quite funny so look f6 is not the way to
go however black can win and it's quite
funny and really strange more team in a
way black can win here with the move
night to g6 that's quite nice the idea
is that with the night retreating to g6
we make sure that the White King cannot
move at all the e7 square here is now
under control by the night and this
means white cannot move the king and the
sets up a decisive threat look f6 mate
yeah white can only only stop it with
this for at the moment and again we need
to be cautious we cannot capture then
the king is escaping however what we can
do is we keep we can keep him in the
mating net and this happens with look at
seven this is this is strong because now
we all of a sudden threaten this
checkmate night f8 mate they are really
great and white can try to defend with
97 check yeah I note that this is again
spoiling the whole effort but we can
take here I'm sorry and here again the
king is in a mating net white in this
position has no defense against 96 night
f8 checkmate the king is in a total of
mating net it's really great something
like let's say G 396 verse 9 f8 met
coming he has no defense whatsoever it's
really fantastic so Quincy for would
have been an interesting try to defend
but ultimately it it wouldn't have
wouldn't have worked um yeah what else
can white try something else he can try
night efore in this position yeah trying
to take here I know it looks crazy
because it's a self fork but it's a it
would be immensely helpful if black is
taking one of those pieces he has much
better move the best move is to take one
take the Queen effect here and after 96
we have a checkmate again with night g6
yeah funny we threaten this made white
can try to fit
this offer the moment but ultimately the
white king will be checkmated it's
really really funny okay if we go back
to the game what what did wyd play in
fact he played the move Knight d5 yeah
this is designed to cover the f6 mating
square this mating square where the
ruckus delivering mate yeah and now what
should like do in fact the the easiest
is what he played he took the Queen and
just continues to play this position
with the White King being a desperate
shape on e6 the big problem still is
there is the knight on d5 hanging and
this night cannot really move whenever
it moves this rook f6 mate yeah so if
white now is let's say giving this check
yeah we are just just moving the King
away and have rook f6 next there's
really no way to defend this off with a
night on your 7 the night it's blocking
if they owned their own square for the
king so it's a it's still a very very
big big problem and why played Bishop d3
here and here um black now found a good
reliable way to win it is not the most
precise way the computers is telling a
Stella me that white can a black hand
give a mate and seven actually but this
is not very realistic in a game to see
all those things the the quickest made
here is not sorry it's rock d to e 8
which looks a bit strange because it
allows night is heaven check but it is
in fact really the quickest way to win
97 check um King I guess h8 King d6 this
at first looks weird but it is a movie
is really a maid because of this strong
move the point is that this is a maid
and white now has to go to c7 after
which
this mate is happening that's quite nice
so very a very nice checkmate seein ya
an ID rook da twas a bit better but ok
it's not really matter in that much what
black did instead of this move he played
the move g6 this is also quite good it
gives the black king this flight square
after checks and with the King on g7
you're preparing rook f6 again and
possibly just make sure that the night
is not going anywhere it just is just a
good strengthening move and black can at
all times um take the knight on d5 as
well now note that this is impossible in
case you something goes wrong yeah but
wyd really has no defense he played rook
age to everyone and black now played
King to g7 yeah just activating this
king of it and trying to again going for
going forward checkmating setup for
example there are many ways that you can
try to checkmate you for example this is
the threat rook e8 yeah if white is
doing nothing let's say why display
playing a nothing move then we have this
check yeah note that the King cannot go
to f5 this is one of the benefits of the
g6 97 and then bishop age 4 or rooty
seven what is better rakta sabnur much
might even be might even be better yeah
this is good enough with rookie to e7
take c7 mate coming so g6 took away an
important for in-flight square yeah
white in the game he played what did he
play 94 he played and then we had this
this and Bishop h4 yeah okay this is a
bit
front but the same idea now why tried
Bishop takes g6 ruki 7 King f5 check
again yeah the White King didn't have
much fun in this game King to e4 and Tia
black just took on g6 with check a very
understand of a practical decision
especially if black was in some sort of
time trouble you never know it wasn't
exactly easy this game um if the thing
is a black also could have made it here
with d 555 was a direct checkmate with
this double check king here ruby three
made yeah this would have been a bit
quicker but 96 it's just the kind of
decision you you calculate you have
little time and you just think okay I'll
take this with check and win the game
one hundred percent so I'll take it and
and it's okay you don't see the mate
it's not a big issue a practical sense
ok King d3 the check here and the bishop
f2 and here the white player resigned he
is a piece and a pawn down and has no no
counter play whatsoever yeah so a really
enjoyable game with the Great King Hunt
who really rarely see the white king um
on this this longer longer journey in a
game if we just briefly look at it again
we have this this amazing situation
where blanket sacrificing the Queen and
in return we get to chase the White King
all the way up to d5 and even after this
c6 King e6 a pair of moves we get the
King to e6 and here we don't take the
Queen but we castle yeah i really i
really like this it's a great it's a
great game and not so well known so i
hope that this little gem of a game is a
was was new to you yeah i hope you
enjoyed it um and it it shows that
sometimes knowledge of those very basic
opening traps like
this legals mating trap this is early
Jack it can help you maybe sometimes
find more sophisticated things over the
board just sharpens your your sends a
bit for for those tactics that that
might happen here it was a bit different
but still the same motif with taking
only for using the the not so perfect
pin on the Queen yeah hope you liked it
thanks for watching